in a perfect world when it came to
choosing an occupation
we would have only two priorities in
mind
firstly to find a job that we enjoyed
and secondly to find a job that paid us
enough to cover
reasonable material needs
but in order to think so freely we would
have to be emotionally balanced in a way
that
few of us actually are in reality
when it comes to choosing an occupation
we tend to be haunted by
three additional priorities we need
to find a job that will pay not just
enough to cover
reasonable material expenses but a lot
more besides
enough to impress other people
even other people we don't like very
much
we also crave to find a job that will
allow us not to be at the mercy of other
people
whom we may deep down fear and distrust
and we hope for a job that will make us
known
esteemed honoured and perhaps famous
so that we will never again have to feel
small or neglected
needless to say these three additional
requirements
make working life hugely more
complicated and unhappy
than it would otherwise have needed to
be no wonder we may get stuck
choosing what to do rather than being
able to focus on the jobs that we are
passionate about
and that we would intrinsically enjoy we
have to twist our natures
to appease extrinsic imperatives
there is no way that we could for
example work as a kindergarten teacher
a psychotherapist a carpenter or a cook
our psychological drive to impress to
have power over others
and to be known to strangers preclude
such relatively modest choices from the
outset
the state of our psyches means that we
have to aim for far more stellar careers
even in fields we don't really much like
and we may have to work much harder than
is good for our health or our families
we're prone to be constantly panicked
because the bar for failing is so much
higher
a slight wind of disapproval from the
public might be experienced as appalling
a bit less money than the astronomical
sum we made last year
will register as fateful under pressure
we may make unwise and hasty moves we
might cut corners
involve ourselves in risky schemes and
not give our work the time
and calm it needs what would enable us
to make the right career choices
is something that seems on the face of
it to have nothing to do with work at
all
love a profound experience of love
in both childhood and adulthood
a child who is properly loved is a
creature who doesn't need to prove
itself in any significant way
it doesn't have to excel at school
dazzle acquaintances
or shore up a parent's fragile sense of
esteem
it may do well at school anyway but
because it enjoys the work
not because it has to boost a parent it
can find its way to its own pleasures
it doesn't need to amaze because it's
special enough
just by existing it may end up working
extremely hard
but it will do so because it is
passionate not because it craves
applause it can concentrate on doing a
job
very well while unimpeded by any worries
as to whether it will be known in a
hundred years
or to people in another city it can
potter away in obscurity
deriving gratification from the business
at hand
an experience of adult love further
enhances
the sense of security we need when
someone properly loves us
their patience concern and tenderness
make us feel
rooted and welcome on the earth it
doesn't really matter if no one knows
who we are
and if there's very little left over at
the end of the month
two people who are in love will be happy
to sleep on a park bench
wrote d.h lawrence an idea which may not
be literally true
but which conveys well enough what room
for maneuver
love gives us in relation to our
material priorities
it follows that when people crave power
fortune and fame
it isn't greed that's driving them but
an anguished feeling of being
unloved for which we can feel enormous
compassion
they may look like winners they are in
reality
unhappy victims excessive achievements
are the legacy of an emotionally damaged
sense
that it isn't enough just to be
it may have become second nature to us
to try to fix emotional wounds through
our career choices and exploits
we may not even realize what we're up to
we should dare to ask
what might i have done with my life if i
had felt properly loved from the start
and we may have to acknowledge with
tears in our eyes how different
our path would have been how many
genuine ambitions
we sacrificed in the name of shoring up
a sense of acceptability
we should have had from infancy the most
astonishing career achievements
will never compensate anyone for the
lack of love they've suffered
work cannot fix a deficit of love
we should enjoy work on its own terms
and in another part of our lives
mourn and seek redemptive substitutes
for the love
we originally lacked
how to get on with your colleagues
provides a guide to the most
difficult aspect of the workplace
creating harmonious working
relationships
you